we're ready ready alright ladies and
gentlemen technical difficulties but
another episode of your favorite podcast
[Music]
singing Mike I like it I was offered to
the guests just with the wig Griffin
that's what I do in the streets of
Century City you know how we I'm not a
rapper it's not always good but today we
got the very funny mister
[Applause]
anyway we did it no that's great can I
take these off now yeah you can take
them off first before we even start the
podcast can I say I've never seen
somebody so stressed I know I saw four
podcast starts it's just because every
time you know you got it all set up and
every time it's ready to go I think I
got it done and then the person comes in
the room and then the mic goes out the
monitoring doesn't work the sound and
I'm like what because I'm over here by
myself three things go wrong as soon as
I set it up but we it's all taken care
of now maybe this is a good energy for
our podcast and any time you need this
thing I'm like you can go to it once I
got my candles and all that but anyways
let me get you on ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the podcast who I met at the
light skin meetings the very funny mr.
Michael yo yes this is our fraternity
like yes so there we are welcome to the
podcast
what do you got to say you know what I I
feel that you know I'm jealous are you
why is that because I love your career I
love that your movies I love that you do
stand-up I love how you're doing the
whole acting thing you've been doing an
acting thing I love that and that's the
next level I'm trying to crack because I
came from entertainment right I work for
e extra anything would it e I worked in
it you know what I mean so now it's kind
of like I'm shedding that skin and now
I'm evolving as a comic and I love like
now I want to move into the acting yeah
you know when I look up honestly I look
up that you're in a lot of different
things I appreciate you saying that but
the grass is always greener on the other
side what I'm finding is the
entertainment business has changed so
drastically in the last like five or six
years I think this is the first time
okay
this is the first time that just being a
comic is a viable thing that like and
also super lucrative like you're talking
about like some of the best in the game
you know like Bill burr and these kind
of people that you know even though
he does some acting roles he's a comic
you know he's selling out 4,000 Cedars
and it's a comic and it's like and it's
okay it's on the same par as its others
well what's interesting is you know my
job for all these entertainment outlets
was to interview celebrities at onset
like I would go to set and I remember
when Modern Family was that as big as
you know everybody thought it was a
funny show still funny it's still great
and I went on set and it was Julie Bowen
and Ty Burrell and they were go oh my
god we heard you do stand-up comedy how
do you look how do you do that huh so
even the biggest actor I know they
respect comedian so much because it's
the one thing they can't do yeah but
here's okay again though here's the
thing so I would venture to say that
when you were doing your thing
you were always a funny guy mm-hmm and
then it kind of was in the ether of like
oh well maybe I could go into stand-up
comedy you know it never I never thought
about going in and saying that but you
did though I did though yeah so you did
so it no no it is true you were at a
point where like now let me ask you this
the reason you went have sent into
stand-up comedy wasn't it a lot of it
like somebody said to you you know you
can make a lot of money you know you can
like you know you can take your fans and
you could like sell out theaters and
things like that had nothing to do with
it okay it was a dare okay so I was on
Chelsea Lately and but I was the
reporter on Chelsea Lately so I would
they would have three comics and then me
so Chelsea made fun of me because it was
I was the celebrity kiss-ass so I had to
tell facts about the celebrity they
couldn't all bash the celebrity right
right so they would say mean things
about the celebrity and I would come in
well you know they did sell fifty
million dollars worth it yeah and then
everybody would make fun of me that was
my role so then after three years
everywhere I flew people go why don't
you do stand-up uh-huh and then I
tweeted the night before I was on
Chelsea yeah I think I'm gonna try the
stand-up thing right because I jo koy
was the one that was like dude you need
to do it you got a great story because
me and him always used to riff back and
forth yeah yeah so Chelsea challenged me
on it the next day she goes you think
it's easy to do stand-up I go well I'm
sitting here at this table it doesn't
look too hard you know Wow
shots fired all the columns I got all
the chills
so all the copies got mad I mean play
mad and then I tried it for the first
time in Miami at the old Miami improv
yeah and did 15 minutes but I was just
telling family stories right and
literally it was the first time ever I
walked offstage called my mom and go
this is what I was born to do like I
never knew I could love something so
much okay okay well that's cool
all right so but like I'm saying though
there is still a part of it the business
part of it is like look I got all these
fans from Radio from E and it's like
this will translate over very nice well
yes cuz the first time I had a Miami
radio show a big Miami and I sold out
the first but first my first show ever
that practice show it sold out because I
had such a big show on the radio now
that's exactly what I saw the potential
you so what I'm saying is you brought
the audience before you brought the
talent a hundred percent you know 100
percent so but I went oh okay so what
I'm saying though is that stand up I
believe for a short time now for the
less I say in the last ten years in a
ten-year span here people have seen that
like oh wow if you have fans a great way
to reach your fans is a live performance
yeah it'll come see you live so the
people would do a stand but you got
people like Dustin Diamond and like Mike
McDonald from MADtv like he started
doing stand-up really late in his life
and career you know like you know I did
a show with him as well I know this and
like people are screaming Stu they
wanted to do the characters and he
didn't want to do it cuz he wanted to do
his stand-up you know but the place was
sold out it was packed
so I'm sick but now what I'm saying is
the reason how the business has changed
now is like now people are doing this oh
yeah so it's funny that you're saying
you want to get into what you think I'm
doing it's like you know and I'm saying
to you is like no no what's happening
now is people are now going into what
you started in yeah yeah it's true I
remember the biggest mistake I made was
and this is the ego in me 11 years ago
Chris Hardwick I I did a show basically
I got hired at eBay and I got trying to
do stand-up yeah trying to do stand-up
so I but this is the biggest mistake I
made they open they made me a studio
across from Ryan Seacrest so literally
see him Ryan Seacrest every day and made
me believe I can do what he's doing too
Chris Hardwick at the time goes hey man
you want to be a part of my podcast and
I go podcast I'm on real radio I don't
need like in my head
that's how is it was just starting and
he goes no you should I'll help you
start your own podcast I was like nah I
got I'm doing real radio I do real radio
I don't pad cast one like five people
listened to and he was a dude I'm
telling you it's gonna be bit I was like
dude get out of here and that is the I
wish I would have started podcasting 11
yeah yeah and I wish she'd be in a
thousand episodes I'd be like thirty
thousand the thing about it too is it be
your thing I did Rogen not too long ago
and I called you for advice when I did
Rogen look at you now after you know
what some flight way I like to cut you
off but cuz I'm thinking I think we had
the same journey absolutely the same
journey it's like I've been trying to
start a podcast I went talking about I
see all my friends and making all this
money but I go I don't know if that's
and then I go on Rogan okay and then
after Rogan I was on Rogan say on a
Wednesday and I was at the Irvine improv
that weekend the first time ever I got
like bonuses and like the place was like
jam-packed from the front to the back
and I was like oh oh it clicked I need
to start a podcast I remember walking
into Rogan yeah cuz we you've been there
so you see the complex and it's a
complicated compound so a compound so I
remarried right up and I go which door
do I go in which one is his and I all
the doors are his every door in that
building is the whole thing so I walked
in and I go oh it hit me right there
because I'm like you I know the Brendan
shops the Thiel Vons the I know
everybody but until you walk in to an
empire and you can even know the money
Rogan makes you know but it's kind of
that thing I compared to me and Ryan
Seacrest when I lived in Miami I never
thought I could be on TV till I was
right across the hallway from him and
saw him every day and then I go oh I can
do that too it makes you believe when
you actually there so when I saw what he
built from podcasting I go okay
literally two weeks later my podcast was
up and run so we had the same experience
but also let's not I don't want to
diminish it either and say that it's
just one it's not just about money it's
not that it's about like the engagement
you have with your fans how you
now one away from your fans to something
that you are doing this is my
personality I'm speaking to my people
and the people that want to watch me
it's not filtered through like no well
you have to the demographics and you
have to worry about all this [ __ ]
about commercials and like you know you
know the marketing and no it's like I am
speaking to right now Eric Griffin fans
and that's what's so but that's what's
true like I remember when I was on Rogan
after Rogan he said because I used to
have no Michael yo show on another
platform and he goes why you letting
somebody else on your content he goes
you should own your own content he goes
and he said don't think about the
millions of people that other people
have listening he says just find your
people and he goes if it's two people if
it's 200,000 people if it's Millions
guess what those are your people and
they will support you through thick and
then they're the ones that come out to
the shows and you know what's funny too
is I realized this too is like you know
it's it's okay let me just backtrack so
you had Blockbuster Video yeah okay so
so Blockbuster Video was like getting
everybody's movies in it and then
there's just streaming platform Netflix
decided they go hey you know what we
can't do it like this you don't need
Blockbuster Video and then everybody's
giving them content and then now people
are like the people that make the
content are like wait why are we letting
Netflix show our stuff and now they're
like we could have our own app we're
gonna have our own thing so then the
entertainment business is expanding that
way right it's the same thing with us
now like you know what I'm thinking
about like I'm putting my own standup
clips on the Internet
oh yeah you know like like like why like
like Andrew Schultz has shown us the way
a new way of doing things to like and
say why am I like why are my clips on no
offense to whatever comedy club why am I
on that comedy clubs website and they're
putting it on YouTube they're generating
the monetization for YouTube and I say
hold on hold on that's my [ __ ] oh no and
and you see no clubs clubs are way
smarter than the comics a long time ago
obviously cuz clubs I mean since Dave
Chappelle they have Dave Chappelle clips
that are running and running and running
and all these big comics that break they
got their clips you shoot it in the club
you do now it's
it's great to see comments who's
stepping up and go hey if I don't want
you to tape you can't tape right before
they were just tape you know what I mean
so now they're not owning the content as
much but it's kind of like you said
we're putting the content on our own
platform and I'm compared to you I'm new
to the stand up game but I caught the I
caught to tell in when you know like the
Comedy Store wasn't crowded and
comedians were like oh they were cool
but now it's like oh what's great about
it is you own everything from your
stand-up to your podcast yeah you kinda
have to for me in this town to stay just
positive you're gonna hear a lot of
knows every casting you go to is pretty
much 90% is knows most of the
entertainment is most of it is nose but
when you control your own content from
stand up to podcasting and when those
people watch right now and go oh I love
this podcast that's your people yeah
that's a yes
even I think it's an outlet when you get
that know you get a bunch of nose in
casting but you can go to a club rock it
in front of 400 people and get 400 yeses
for being yourself that's what's great
to me about staying about yeah I told
agree I mean but I think that what I
love about it now is just seeing how
stand-up has turned into you know like I
said it is turned into like on par with
you know it's like acting stand-up cuz
when I came up stand-up was a means to
an end
you know that's that's how it was how
long have you done it I've been doing
this since 2003 but but just even from
knowing about it back then that's what
I'm saying it's like it was all like you
did stand-up so you could get on a show
you know what I mean yeah and then after
that you're off and running but now like
I'm saying it's like you know like I
just I was in San Diego this past
weekend have to lower your Comedy Store
and I love that plane I like Chris
D'Elia was doing theater gigs in San
Diego at the same time you know and when
I went to go hang out with him
afterwards and I was like oh this is I
was like oh look at this guy like I
remember when he was coming up and I'm
like but now it's like this is a viable
like on par with whatever movie
someone's gonna do these comics are out
here now paving away and it all starts
it all stems from in my opinion you know
the the internet like the social
influence you know because like you know
now
this is a thing you know like like it's
the everybody's gets a little Empire you
know and you can find an audience
because you know what's crazy it's like
delay is such a good dude but it's like
he treats that like he's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah he's always been great to me it's
kind of like that thing where you know
you gotta approach social media now it's
a job yeah it is you know like Celia
thinks about like I've talked to whit I
remember it was one of those awkward
situations where he sat right next to me
on a plane ride from New York to LA and
we were friends but you know you and I
know we both were thinking it but we got
he told me about that trip yeah but we
got so deep into where he really puts a
lot of thought into what he's doing even
though it looks like he's not and I
think that's the brilliance of oh sure
like he was like on a ground floor of
like vine and snapchat yeah he was using
it as a tool he said you know a dynamic
personality it's just it's just like for
me I haven't found out what's my thing
what your thing is I think you're just
you're translating your persona cuz even
right now I find you to be like in a
mode right now yeah I got feeling
feeling like right now you're in Michael
yo mode you know even your your voice
your inflection and things like that and
it's like you know I think you've always
have known how to like sell yourself
yeah I think you've always known how to
like but tell me this like you know when
you to go from an area of like that that
has fans and is out there and then when
you switched over to stand up did you
feel pressure did you feel guilt did you
feel anything like it's like oh I didn't
come up like everybody else
well did you gel see it from people it's
like what here's the thing you know me
I'm a positive person so I will say this
I remember when Chelsea heard that you
know I was doing solid in sin and this
is only like my first six months okay
yeah it's like okay it looks like you're
gonna be doing this she goes be in the
clubs
make sure comics see you don't be that
guy that just shows up now in hindsight
I wish I was a lot better when those
crowd cuz I was selling out places
because I was back then if you were on
Chelsea
lately a regular you were selling out a
tire now it's crazy
you were selling out everywhere and I
started comedy like two years in they
started having me tour but I would bring
like five comics I brought like britmore
and I would bring five comics put myself
in the middle so I was smart about that
and not trying to headline it so I would
just do it to work out time and we
called hot-mess comedy tour so I was
always helping and bringing comics with
me because I didn't have the time so I
always showed love so that was your way
okay now there was one comic that hated
on me
uh and I'm friends with him now and they
don't even know I know you know it's one
of those things and like basically it
was I was only four months in MTV was
gonna do a reality show about comics
they were just trying to break it so
they came out to shoot me at the brain
improv the old Brea improv and this
person was [ __ ] talking me in front of
my friend and they didn't realize it was
your friend that was my good friend and
we're cool today but I know what he said
and he has no idea I know
oh and it was the first time I've ever
got hated on just for trying or maybe
the first time you heard about it heard
about yeah hey we're trying to do
something that other people were doing I
can't remember people hating on you I
yeah if I could think back to the time
because it's one of these things worse
like first of all there's no right or
wrong way and I'm not saying it's right
you know cuz I I had Angela Johnson on
yeah and she discussed the same kind of
thing I was like you know she went from
rags to riches you know it was you know
it was like this bit and then they were
like we need you to headline you know
yeah and then she was like okay I'll do
it but she never did she never did that
she wasn't a part of the Brotherhood
yeah a hundred I feel like you know I'm
not part of the Brotherhood because you
know we're thinking more part of it now
I am but I'm not in the club like my
thing is like a person like I don't know
your backstory but I imagine you hung
out at the Comedy Store you met a lot of
people right I came in two years three
years in then I was married or like four
or five years in I was doing it but I
never had to hang out in clubs because I
was already touring right exact so I
didn't develop the only people I really
know or the Condorcet I know I get you I
totally get this listen I'm not I don't
feel bad about this I
feel bad because you skipped it's like
people think oh you skipped a step
oh yeah but I feel that I also did more
I skipped a step 100% but I worked on
other things yeah you would you brought
to this to this yeah in a position you
can skip that step well you know and
it's like I I'm not I'm not mad at it
I'm seeing it more now because of like I
said doing podcast look I was on Logan
Paul's podcast you know impulsive and
everybody was you know half the people
were like well you guys like whatever
[ __ ] you you know the kids he did what
he did you know he's a dumb kid and he
figured it out and he like he mounted he
figured it out yeah we're allowed to
make mistake and he's still monetized
yeah yeah exactly still it's still like
in the tops on the YouTube you know but
anyways five years ago I was in a movie
of his I think it was like almost five
years ago at the time he was so intense
about like like how you're talking about
like weekend on TV you wanna do movies I
wanna do this I want to do that and it
was like now he could care less
yeah because all those guys all those
influencers only King batch is the only
one that's like I want to be because he
was classically trained he went to
acting school so he always wanted he
just figured a Lane but what I'm saying
is like what we think we want to do like
whatever our motivation is like this
social media and being an influencer and
YouTube and these things like that's
actually an end game now Oh a hundred
percent you know what I mean it's it's a
thing where it's a monster these kids
like they got a eight-year-old making
twenty two million dollars a year on
YouTube by opening I and now it's crazy
it's like ridiculous so you know what's
funny about that too though is that when
you look at the top that so you google
the top ten top 25 highest-paid YouTube
people none of them do podcasts they
don't have to I don't know what I'm
saying it was like that's how lucrative
YouTube is because I'm saying it's like
we have the same friends who we know are
making a huge they're crushing it in
life of make on podcasting and you know
and they're not even sniffing the 15 20
million dollars that these people
making it you don't even know it's like
so it's the wild wild west is great it
is it's a direct-to-consumer is it's
open season it's just take advantage of
the situation but my thing is it's just
owning owning everything you do you know
and you and we talked about that so why
you want to get in acting and film and
all that well because I want to learn
I'm always open to learning like I want
to learn that because if it's kind of
like comedy once you'd learn something
and I love stand-up comedy but once you
learn something then you kid okay now I
know how to act
I can produce my own movie or I can do
this right now I know nothing about like
directing that like I want to learn that
craft too because you know you never
know how you following the things it's
like comedy I didn't know I was gonna
fall into it like it was but once I got
in it I became a nerd like after shows I
talk for five hours I write about like
all the time about like you know I love
it so much you know so it's a thing
where I'm in it you know and I feel that
I I skipped a step but I put my heart
and soul into it and to bring it and to
bring that to a level where you know I
feel comfortable going on or before
anybody now by the way that's an
unnecessary step it's just a step that
we're saying in terms of like if you
wanted to be a part of like this like
Brotherhood of people who mostly aren't
making it I tell you does it does hurt
you because I'm not gonna lie to you and
this is such a Hollywood thing but I was
talking to my agent and I was going I
was going you know what I perform with
everybody but I'm not considered I feel
like I'm not considered a comedian to
the industry you know what I mean like I
performed with everybody like I'm on
every show and everybody but when it
comes to certain TV shows where they're
putting on a lot of comedians like I
won't get asked to do those even though
and this is no hate even though I'm
touring across the country and a lot of
these people that are on these shows
haven't reached that level yet it's just
I'm not considered they're considered
more of a comedian than I am maybe
because where they're playing The Comedy
Store etc and I so my thing is like how
do I spot does it bother you it does it
does
yeah because I'm gonna be respected by
the comedians now do
do I care here's what's interesting do I
want to be respected yes do I care what
other comedians think about me no it's a
weird thing it's a very weird thing like
I wouldn't know I think what you mean to
say is like I don't care if people like
me or not yes but I do want to respect
yes that I'm doing this yes yes yes yes
so that's like like if a comic said you
know what he sucks on stage but I see
him touring I respect that you know
but it's that weird thing where I'm not
in that where you are you know what I
mean yeah but but I don't even know what
that is but it is something but it is
something and I feel like there are
comedians I think if you were talking to
communities they'd be like oh yeah I
like Eric he's funny or whatever it is
like that but like what I'm seeing is
like that don't translate to getting
butts in the seats no but see you're
looking at I respect more about your
what you've done as a business person in
comedy more so than you know the comedy
you know you know when you first got in
I'm saying you know what I mean
so like for me I'm like I'm I'm behind
I'm rethinking the whole thing that's
why I'm late to the party I was like oh
this is how you do it so now like I
don't think about these things anymore
like we were talking about off air here
is that you know like I'm about to do
some dates with Dane on his tour you
came on my podcast and we were talking
about it and I was like yeah do some
dates with you you know I mean I want to
be and he was surprised he was like oh
I'm well I think you'd want to do that
you know and I'm like my thing is like
he's selling 5,000 tickets at some place
I'm barely filling a comedy club so yeah
yeah let me go do that let me go do this
fun thing can I tell you what's so crazy
is you'll hear different people like
this is what I love about comedians -
you talk about you'll hear 20 different
answers and you'll talk to agents and
going well you can't open for him you're
you're trying to be a headliner and it's
like okay guess what if you don't open
for people then that Club like no I'm
not talking about us but I've taken out
a lot of people that their management
has been like oh you can't open for him
because we're trying to get you to
headliner status guess what I'm bringing
you to a club and that owner may like
your set and go oh I need to well yeah
but you know what though I actually
disagree with you I actually disagree
with you hundred Oh what I disagree with
you that that's
it doesn't work like that you know I
don't know I've had several comments go
out with me and then they're regulars
now and Comedy Works and different
places like that yeah I'm sure but like
there is something to be said about
building your own way like I knew when I
got into it I didn't want a feature for
people okay
I just didn't I did it a couple times
and I was like now I want to do this so
I'd rather go out in like so you know
start is like a low-paying comic and get
you know and you know but even when I
look back on that I don't even know if
that was my thing was I will I offer all
the time to open for people because I'm
just trying to reach all everybody's
fanbase yeah cuz then I totally agree
with you if I can get a hundred people
two hundred people in every market it's
different so different I get it I get
there so when when like for me like
where we may disagree well I don't mind
opening for people even though I'm a
headliner now I guess in the industry
I'm a headliner but I don't like for
instance orny Adams is doing a show and
it Gotham I happen to be in town now if
they're not gonna announce me or
anything but I'm gonna go in and pop on
two of his shows that's different
that's different especially a city like
that how's it different though because
cuz cuz I just did that too I was in
Boston I was filming a movie in Boston
and like a mere K was that yeah laughs
and I went and I hopped on the show but
you were openly on yeah but it's not the
same as like it's not the same as like
you're at the Comedy Works doing six
shows and it says you know whoever
featuring Michael yo opening yeah but
they still had that on the on the thing
this is still there but what I'm trying
to say there was like popping in and
somebody's friend it's not the same as
like you know open like like even what
I'm doing with Dane is not like I we pre
discussed it and it was like okay I'm
gonna be on the tour with you yeah you
don't mean like would you do that and
I'm realizing now as I oh I should do
that also I was in Boston and Eric Andre
was in town okay he was doing a theater
gig you know what I mean and like Eric
Andre's show it actually is very much
like a podcast and it is it's very
cific fans and their rabid fans and they
love him so he's selling out this huge
theater and I hit him up oh hey man here
in town he's like come do it do some
time you know what I mean
and then like I went out on stage as a
special guest you know and that age
group knows workaholics all this and
they just went crazy and I was like oh I
love this yeah but why would you want my
thing is why would you want to take that
opportunity away oh I know that's what
I'm saying though so what I'm trying
what I'm realizing right now we're
seeing the same thing right now okay
beginning you know because I disagree
that like I disagree that like when when
when a manager says hey we don't want we
don't want you to go open for someone
because we're trying to get you a
headliner on that particular level of
like comedy clubs I agree with that in
some sense because when you when you are
you don't believe it exposure in kimono
is exposure to who the fans know that
fans yes to comedy club people once they
think your feature your a feature see oh
okay yeah once the comedy club if a
comment comes at your feet it's just
like when you're on a when you had a
business let's say you're working a
business right
they hired you from within right when
it's time for promotions they don't
always oh I know that they don't always
like to give people a promotion from
within they like to hire out or or if
they do give the promotion they're not
gonna pay you for the promote exactly
yeah I I worked and put it like this I
worked at a company when I first moved
down here and they pay me nothing I left
and did a couple other things then they
gave me all the money when I went back
you have to leave my point this is a
point I'm saying man it's a point I'm
saying is like sometimes I feel like cuz
the comedy club if I'm a comedy club
owner I want the best show possible
right so if I could get a headliner and
I could get a dude that like could be a
headliner as the featured that's a great
show you know like my job is not to
promote you I could care less about your
career my job as a club owner is to fill
seats well put on a good show
see I know relationship like that
anymore you really think that these
clubs are out here like yes they're not
certain certain ones yeah
I disagree I say Wendy from Comedy Works
it's like that Stephanie from Chicago in
profits like that very few i but there
are out there yeah I'm telling you okay
thank you I mean I don't know all the
old you're right you're right I don't
know but I don't know I just never had a
problem feature but by the way those
places you just mentioned they're not
there it's not like they're there that
that person that they're bringing in
they're gonna pay a lot of money either
then why would you pay a lot of money to
a feature that's signal about when that
feature now becomes their headliner yeah
you think they're gonna do you think
they're going well okay but that's what
I'm saying so but what we're finding out
right now is you have to build that
reputation and legacy outside of comedy
yeah well it's a lot faster if you can
well you know what you're that's how
it's supposed to be now yeah and and by
the way that's what you did
mmm-hmm and that's okay you like you
were like all right cuz the point is to
get people to come watch you then it's
like you brought this audience from this
other thing and then you're respecting
the craft by continuously working on it
you know I mean we're we're we're I feel
that we're I do I don't get mad at
anybody but I do feel people do chief
like here's the thing I skipped a step
but I don't feel like I cheated the
system because I put in the work right
where you'll have a youtuber and I'll
see two comments open up for a youtuber
that do an hour and then this youtuber
comes around and jumps around for like
15 minutes even though the place is sold
out and that's all I care about and
that's all I care about that's all the
clubs care about so a lot of them so my
point yeah they just want butts in seats
yeah I'm saying is it not respecting
Comedy liked it like like do I see like
like that Club you're talking about the
head is YouTuber open you know still the
place out why aren't they going like
well let me get let me grab like some
features or get a bit featuring at my
club for so long and give them an
opportunity because I don't sell tickets
mm-hmm that's why yeah like I had a
situated its
country something or other oh yeah yeah
yeah who's that use that J that's a long
word Chris red dude that was at
Huntsville I was in Huntsville yeah
doing a show and for some reason they
booked me at the seven o'clock they
booked me at the nine o'clock show so he
was doing a seven o'clock show both
nights and I'm doing the nine o'clock
show
up nightmare you know it's like you know
like there was no like mutual respect
it's like the green room was full of
people that I don't even know I was like
I never had an opportunity to be like is
this my show at anytime you know he's
running he's doing a meet-and-greet on
the show during the time that my chela
supposed is supposed to start people are
outside waiting in the weather like you
know because he's doing that and then he
had no like hey sorry about that and
there was no mutual respect nothing is
this after he got yelled at no this was
this was before this was before man he
had no he just no respect at all for the
thing you know but you don't understand
that unless you come up that's what I'm
saying yeah that's one well I think
that's when comics mean when they go
they think that it's a fine line where
they think that maybe you need to
struggle a little bit you need to know
what it's like I don't agree with that
but there is something about respecting
the craft and and the comedy process I
think you got a I think if you're that
dude like I forgot his name but the
country got yours huh but I think for me
when I got in since I know I said like I
know I skipped this out I educated
myself so much with comedy in the
comedian's and you know the history of
it and it's the thing where you know I I
go to shows all the time still today
I'll go to other people's shows and I
hate to question what are you doing here
you're going up tonight now I'm just
here watching and okay like that's weird
for people why it's so called
Brotherhood full of [ __ ] yeah and really
right you feel do you feel like there's
really no Brotherhood or no no I just
have good friends you know I feel like
it's a process of life like the army and
it's like you know somebody that didn't
have to go to boot camp you gonna be
like you go to boot camp who the [ __ ]
are you you know I mean like they like
we want people to go through the things
that we paying you in for the pain so we
can understand but what I'm realizing is
if that's not necessary it's not
necessary
here's the thing you can't force pain on
people if they go through it no it's
just it's just different time it's just
a different eras just different times
and you know it's funny cuz I feel from
you how this bothers you oh yeah I could
tell it just really bothers yeah you
know and I and I ain't you know and it's
like and I'm thinking in my mind like
what could be done about it I guess it's
just a matter of
time well here's what can be done about
when you start selling out arenas then
here's what's funny is you know they're
like the Sebastian's - bill burr joke or
I was sitting down with joke like here's
what I love about jo koy being my mentor
he was never accepted into the comedy
brethren either really if you he was
right he just did wasn't around anymore
he just took off
yeah but what I'm saying is you he
wasn't getting I've been me and him been
closed for 12 years yeah he wasn't on
those shows that all the comedian's are
wrong back then he wasn't part of he was
going through like oh he's funny but
he's not us you know like the first when
I first got into stand-up and I'll never
forget this 11 years ago me and Joe very
close he's my mentor in comedy and I was
at The Improv and I was talking about
him when I would bring up jo koy the
first thing there we go is all that dude
sings at the end of a set that's not
real comedy and I go why are people like
to me he's one of the funniest people
I've you ever see so why are people
hating on him
because he wasn't considered like a
comedian a comedian he's comedian yeah
yes and then I was backstage with one
kameena I'll never forget it and I and
this was nine years ago and I go hey
you're gonna go meet the people after no
I want to keep the being mysterious to
the audience and I was taking pictures
of people giving out cards and guess
what
and no distracted him but he's at the
same place he was back then of course
you know what I mean you see what I'm
saying okay you know what you see this
is what I'm talking about
the business has changed you know the
business had to change even for the
comedy club yeah the reason why the
comedy clubs will put a youtuber in at 6
o'clock in the afternoon and you know
till I do you know five show whatever it
is is because they gotta sell tickets
they got if they gotta feed their
families and that kind of stuff so the
business has changes it's become a
business where the club's themselves
aren't doing any marketing you know they
do and because of no marketing because
they want you to do all the marketing
and also I mean you got to look on the
opposite end too because now the like
the radio stations and the TV station
now you gotta pay money to get on air on
a lot of those places you know so it's
like the comedy clubs put it like this
if a comedy club is paying you five to
ten thousand dollars the comic depending
on ticket sales mm-hmm they're like
we're already gonna pay
this out we're not gonna spend another
three four thousand dollars in radio
advertisement well but but then the bit
the business of comedy is I'd actually
be too inside because sometimes I hate
this but like it's like this though I
say to be a headliner a true headliner
changes the ticket price yeah you know
like you know you you could be a great
comic and close the show put on a great
show headliners changed the ticket price
so they're not losing any money okay
don't don't don't fool yourself yeah
because like if the ticket is regularly
twenty dollars and solo so comes in and
two tickets now fifty dollars yeah okay
they were surviving on the twenty yeah
yeah that's how they paying this person
they giving them 30 and they still
making the twenty and in making even
more because of it yeah you know so
that's why they have these door deals
and they have all these different like
but that's all I'm saying is like the
businesses that's what they don't want
to put the money that's what I'm saying
of course why should I don't want spike
in for that comic you're talking about
they don't need to advertise that gun
right so but but I'm talking about like
a person like me yeah when I come in
depending on the market you I need
advertiser I love press yeah like like
I'm from the mindset I remember me and
Jo koy talking and what comics fail to
realize they'll sell out all these shows
Joe still does all the press we had this
conversation where it was that's free
money literally if you sell out all your
shows yeah and you don't do the press
people pay money to be on TV and this is
not just 5,000 this is it could add up
to one hundred fifty two hundred
thousand dollars if you're doing four or
five TV shows yeah so by you selling out
already and not doing the press in the
radio that means you're just Pat that's
almost like you're just throwing free
money out the window I totally get it
like it yeah we're like again we're our
own entity in a sense so now it's like
actually we've what's great about it if
you think about the other side of it
it's like now we could take charge
actually even of our own advertisement
so because of the internet and all that
then we get fully take charge of it and
be like alright I'm gonna spend fifteen
hundred dollars in this market you know
for like Facebook Ads and all this kind
of stuff this algorithms and there's
things that show that this stuff is
helpful a hundred
klipsch up I mean everybody's out there
now like oh let me reach people you know
it's like it's it's such a simple thing
like we want to reach people and what's
the best way to reach people
it used to be radio TV newspaper
magazines and now it literally is our
phones and do you feel like after you
start your podcast that a huge
difference big difference oh yeah I told
you it was after that day I was like
okay I get it and then now it's like
things are happening that have never
happened in my career 13 years on TV 13
years on TV and here's what Simpson and
people never came to see me the way they
come to see me now here's what's crazy
about TV is I've had friends on TV shows
successful TV shows that doesn't affect
their ticket sales at all it has to be
for some reason the it has to be the
right TV show you know no you know why
cuz they weren't doing any marketing
they weren't using the thing that people
know them for like you did mm-hmm
I'm on radio I'm on E I'm doing all this
hey all you guys over here come check me
out over here see the problem with those
people that are on TV shows is they lazy
as [ __ ] they're making that money they
make it money and they think like wow
more TV people should love me no no like
you said about Joe people still got a do
to work oh yeah and even for myself I
realize up to I realized I wasn't doing
enough work to get people to come see me
perform because people are always like
when they come see my show they're like
you know you're so differ from your
carrot wait a minute so you still get
that today you know this man see that's
two biggest know you were stand-up until
you like a stand-up I really I you know
and but but what is what causes that oh
you're a stand-up now you know what it
could be anything it could be like a
special like Ali Wong special al he's
been funny for years she's a everyone
thought she was funny but like she got a
platform that was like it popped and POW
well let me ask you this you know yeah I
could who's I needs that pal I've never
met Ali but let me just we're talking
about being in the Brotherhood what's
she in that boat before she pop oh yeah
aliens around all the time doing being
around
Jewish shows I'm saying but was she
considered a because Joe was around -
yeah but like people chose different he
got banned from the last factory for
whatever they did I mean Joey that he's
out there personality yeah okay and it's
like look I get I've had I've had the
pretentious comics who think that they
know what comedy is supposed to be get
on me I do I'm I'm on stage I'm lively I
do characters I'll do sound effects I
just I get people bitching at me about
that really oh my god this is the Comedy
Store talking mad [ __ ] about me about
when I was coming up like oh he's always
doing sound effects like [ __ ] you you
mean I'm using my talents to my best of
my ability you can't do what I do and
now the biggest um comedians that are
out have a lot of movement and or big or
they just ever just that's just part of
my thing it's part of you it's me it's
and that's the thing man it's like you
gotta be you and this is what I love and
I've only been doing it like nine years
hardcore so this is what I love to
change I've seen is it's gone from you
gotta just stay in that there and tell
jokes so now it's more storytelling to
now like you can really get people
invested in you I don't think that's
ever changed man I don't I think it's
always more acceptable no I think it's
always been acceptable the thing is it's
just people just aren't good enough ah
you know well then a lot of people have
gotten a lot better at maybe it's more
emphasis on it now I'm just I just think
it depends on who you looking at what
comic you looking like if you look at a
bunch of specials you'll see a lot of
different things not everybody can be
great at stand-up comedy also to take it
to the next step not everybody can be
great at a taping of stand-up comedy
that's what's so interesting is some
people crush live yeah but it doesn't
translate to auntie and what happens see
that's what's so funny to me yeah tell
you what it is yeah what happened not
everybody's photogenic yeah not
everybody pops on screen there's there's
something about that you ever seen like
a model who like I'm talking about on
camera just pops the angles whatever and
they don't look like that necessarily
literally they can take the photo you
look at the phone and go why look at
them and go huh like it's not yeah I
know everybody has that yeah and there's
other
thing of like you know like there's a
certain vernacular there works there's a
certain like you know there's a certain
body language there's a certain like
connection and there's a certain like
thing about the material being invested
in the material or like how that people
deliver it I mean there's no right or
wrong way I'm just saying is not
everybody has found a thing that clicks
and works but I feel like now people
accept everything where when I first
started just nine years ago they didn't
like they weren't open it they were not
open to what in the what way open to
storytelling yeah yeah like you mean
like your storytelling no no just so
Atari in general well people didn't know
if I was good or not at staying though
I'm talking about like comedians I liked
and like I mean my main thing is Joe
like comics did not respect Jo koy at
all like like like the ones at least the
ones I talk to know I look like I get it
because they were like oh he's too
character sings comics don't do that
they stand there and tell jokes like
even the rhythm of jokes like I at least
in my personal experience watching
comedy for nine years it's gone from
because the big thing was like boom boom
like a joke like fifty jokes in a minute
like that but I've never seen that so I
disagree with you but go ahead I see it
all the time no no I get it but what's
it is cuz there's so many comics yeah
the ones that break through they're not
those comics that's what I'm saying I
mean to say they always been here yeah
they just it's just I get what you're
saying though there's like but I again
there's no right or wrong way you got a
guy like Seinfeld Seinfeld say you know
he's oh wait wait wait did we go up no
no this is what I'm saying stay right
here uh-oh what happened okay I was like
what what just happened I might just
leave that into what just happened oh no
cuz I'm looking at whatever is this cast
to industry it might be no no it's okay
we just have no no no see this is what
I'm trying to say this is just like
stand-up we're having an authentic
conversation what we're just talking
about it like we don't have to worry
about like you know what we're
discovering these different things we're
just we're having a point-counterpoint
about what we think is yeah you know you
know and I'm just telling you that I
just think that you know
people just aren't good enough
III story-tell I say that about myself
yeah yeah yeah even for myself like I
haven't reached a level that I've wanted
to reach because I haven't cracked
whatever the thing is I don't know who
my audience is yet I'm still trying to
find it I'm still trying to figure out
what I want to talk about how I want to
talk about it how I want to use my
talents as a comedian as a performer and
and and and and make them come across as
a comedian now I think that's what
people are really talking about when
they were talking about Joe Joe is a
super talented guy he's talented he's a
crusher he can crush you know what I
mean it's like but that doesn't
necessarily translate to like it doesn't
translate to like where you have this
like moment in a special or like a you
know as I got you I got as a comedian
you know what I'm saying but but that
not to say that that's right or wrong
I'm just saying like yeah he used to
irritate me so much when people said
that about you know a guy loved so much
and I thought and I heard a lot and I
would take very I would taken an offense
and it feels so good to see him be so
successful yeah and I look at those
people that said that and I still know
where they are and I'm like no but they
did you're still gonna say that you know
what they're gonna say they're gonna be
like yeah that's because you know people
are dumb and that's the kind of stuff
that you don't have to have popcorn
stuff that people like there's he's
never gonna do you think comics are
still like that oh yeah of course
of course I it was so interested was so
interesting to me it's like a youtuber
man that's that that's that is the
version of in their minds that's a
version of a youtuber selling out the
club because of whatever that is that's
what they think about people that are
like big characters and saying and do
things they don't think of that they
want they think everybody should be like
Chappelle or bill burr or like and it's
like Comi just doesn't work like that
there's so many different types of ways
those guys are just particular to what
they do Joe does what he does yeah you
know what I mean and it just doesn't
fall in line with what the like the
people who probably aren't even really
making it how they do it well that's
what what's interesting to me the people
that aren't really making it are the
ones with the loudest
voices and why you listening I'm not
well I mean I was just get you bothers
you
no not me I'm saying it bothers you did
like when you hear think it's it bothers
me more like I'm to be honest I've never
heard anyone say anything about me
personally oh really
never oh like nobody I just start rose
to be like boom like I've never had
anyone come up and say I don't like just
this and this about you and I've never
had somebody that's hurt something come
up to me and say I've heard this this
and this about because most people are
cowards that's why yeah so and it's not
about the material anything it's just
I've never heard that I've never heard
somebody go after me where people I know
they go after all the time well back
then they go out but I'm not but also
I'm not around a lot of people right so
that's another reason I don't that's
what we talked about yo ass I never he's
taking advantage of the said skip to
step he doesn't hang out this damn what
I'm saying is like what you done people
are catching up to it
so that's so now that the worlds are
colliding and people gonna look back in
retrospect and be like oh man I wish I
would have done that but you know one
thing the negative is when I'm only
three four years in selling out shows I
wish I was a lot better because now like
I'm confident to do any club and I know
it's gonna be a great set back then it
was me developing so you get all like I
remember and not the name drop but I use
interview Kevin Hart a lot and Kevin
Hart said you got to get out your first
special because people don't know you're
a comic kid right and they go they go
they go you go oh no by the way yeah I
have to out people don't become so that
don't mean anything anymore either he
came he came in a different time yeah he
was right before like you know you
didn't mean so good for him but it
doesn't always work like that where
Comedy Central when you had a special on
there it meant a lot more back then even
an HBO special back there yeah it was
like everything now Netflix has such a
lock on the game I get stopped all the
time from people watching my special
that's on Amazon Prime but go man I
loved your special and on that yeah and
they tell you about this but so you know
they watched it yeah but they don't know
they don't know
it's like cleaning it's like a
name-brand like Kleenex yeah it's not a
thing it's like it's a tissue Kleenex is
a brand people say this to me all the
time to man they go and then even like
I'm dying up here people will say like
people bring me out on stage sometimes
like I was in Vegas and the host was
going and an HBO show you know and I'm
like it wasn't on HBO's on Showtime so
people can't find you so I totally get
it I mean like I don't know I mean what
do you think about being like mixed you
do you have a crowd because of that I
started how do you feel like you don't
have a crowd well I'm starting to get a
huge mixed like crowd coming to the show
it just took a while you know my
material literally my material is like
my life you know I'm not a observant
comedian as far as like I like I tell
people I can't write comedy for anybody
else except myself
all right you know I like I'm not a
writer I'm not a comedian right I just
myself I can write my story and that's
pretty much it got you know what I mean
I'm that dude I can tell my stories
great like what what like I went Joe is
my only example because me and him world
together but like I was talking about my
family experiences out the gate when Joe
said it took him 10 years to get to that
point yeah so I'm worse on telling
general jokes about what other people
experience then you know like I haven't
mastered that but family stories I'm in
it like I know I can tell a family story
you know pretty well to me you know what
I mean and the people that like me that
since my dad is black my mom say those
people are coming out any type of mix
people are coming out now so that's
starting to catch on and then people
that just like to hear family comedy and
when I say family comedy I don't mean
it's clean like Jim Gaffigan I mean it's
about my family right Brian you know
what I mean so I do see after my special
came out I did see like you did what I
wanted to do and it still grows it got
me a sitcom deal with Fox you know it
got me it opened the door for a lot of
things because people saw me in a
different light
because it used to be oh you host this
show this Jonas I need to do comedy yeah
now it's like oh you do comedy and you
can host so
the difference in the room so I feel
it's starting to turn over but it wasn't
a huge success like Ali Wong where it
just popped you know like that's
lightning in a bottle
ya know that's not gonna happen
everybody it's not you know so you got
to keep grinding and so now in the next
year I want to shoot my next special you
know so that's the thing I want to put
what out every two and a half I always
appreciated people that like they have
like like I always like those
blue-collar guys yeah like they know
their audience this is their audience
and the audience comes out what's his
name not Kevin Hart because Kevin Hart
is so universal yeah he's universal now
yeah but what oh my god why am I
forgetting that this guy's the the who's
the comedy he had a problem with Tiffany
Haddish you know he was on the radio
targets mag oh it was that uh that was
EPS
no no no not my caps why am I forgetting
this [ __ ] name like I feel like
I know Katt Williams
why did I forget his name Katt also
can't reminded me of the blue collar
guys in a sense of like that he had us
he had an audience debt like wanted to
hear what he had to say and like
everything that he talks about and like
you know what I mean like it was like
and that's a great thing you know but do
you think he has his I mean of course he
has his own audience he sells out
everywhere but is that a time thing or
is that a thing where I don't know man
I don't think there's any rhyme or
reason to it you know I wish if there
was a formula that more people would be
doing it I think I just think that is
like one you once you get that special
thing that like right and that's why
they called it specials but which they
shouldn't be called anymore it's just
content now yeah but like once you find
that whatever that is that really
resonates with people and then that just
that becomes what it is that becomes
yeah yeah so like he just had that thing
you know it's like some people have it
you also come in from different errors
at different times you know it's like
Joe's got a thing like Joe gets a lot of
Filipinos to come on your show so it's
like I don't have nothing like that I'm
from LA
I'm mixed-race people don't know what I
am I look at what are you exactly I
wanted to know yeah people just people
don't know and it's like that's a thing
you're not gonna tell no I never I don't
think it's important
you know to talk about I know it's weird
I know yeah that's why people don't come
you know you wouldn't even tell me what
you are no I'm just I'm just mixed you
know what I mean I mixed you know I mean
I have well you know I have I have said
I have Caribbean roots
okay I'm saying you know like Belize
Jamaica I've got you Central America
I've never met my dad before so this is
the reason why I don't talk about it
yeah because it's like I don't know and
I don't want to go do 23andme and it's
like then it's like you know sometimes I
just don't want to know I identify with
this and I'll just go with that you know
what I mean so are you at the point
where you can talk about your dad on
stage I know because I've nothing to
talk about you know maybe I'll talk
about that I don't know I just never
have gotten to those kinds of things yet
so it's like you know that's what I'm
saying it's like what is the thing
that's gonna make people what and this
is what I'm saying is like to bring it
back to what you were talking about with
Jo koy just being funny
just being funny it's not enough not
today no it's not enough but but but by
the way you can still have an audience I
always respect these people that they
like Elijah Schlesinger somebody that
like Eliza like dad chick she girls are
always like girls ask about two things
they ask about Chris D'Elia you know and
ask about Eliza you know they love her
right maybe it's not my cup of tea you
know when I watch cuz she's not speaking
to me
you know I can respect like the craft
like I'll go like you know you know
sometimes she puts together some really
like I know I love that I love how she
put that to get you know but she's
speaking to her crowd but let me they
love it I've seen her at The Comedy
Store maybe I've never seen her not
crush this room see so what I know but
what I'm saying is like they're still a
faction of people who would be like
that's not my type of comedy however I
do respect that comedy whatever they
people might say so much hate about her
too right and it's about the most it's
interesting but even delay you hear hate
on D'Elia
but yeah barely back back checks you get
when he first started out back in the
day down but yeah he did yeah there was
a lot of like you know infighting
amongst people like whatever they would
say but now hey you know what changes a
success success success makes people go
oh yeah he's tough it's funny how you
know
you're you're a good comic but if
something pops you're a great comment
yeah you know it's kind of like III
compared to because I used to produce a
couple reality shows back in the day and
uh it was funny like if you produce like
Sally she did Jersey Shore and all these
shows her close friends with her she did
Jersey Shore that pop now she's the
biggest thing in TV you know nothing's
changed about her besides they hit TV
show yeah all our other shows were just
as good just nobody watched them yeah
man but you get that one pop now in
Hollywood how it works is like oh now
you get the blessing you can move
forward you know but you're the same
person like I perform with Ali while two
weeks before a special came out
we're like a hundred people in the club
her special came out 5,000 people are in
seats nothing's changed about Ali Wong
in those two weeks
it's just now people it sticks motion
you know she just did like nine shows at
The Wiltern or something I think it was
16 it's good it was amazing it's crazy
it's a mate but but back in two weeks
she wasn't a different person but I also
understand how someone like that now
would be like well you know if she comes
to the country it's funny how sometimes
she comes to the Comedy Store and the
people that come to the Comedy Store
aren't necessarily Ali Wong fans ya know
and she doesn't promote herself you know
which is shows so she comes over she has
different name on the blind up I don't
know if I like that but anyway she comes
a different name on the line yeah yeah
she doesn't have a Ali Wong on a lineup
but I'll say like some weird weird
different name but okay so what I'm
saying is like so then sometimes she'll
be like you know she did Ali Wong and
then the crowd is like okay this is you
know so it's like a weird thing when
you're like you know that big yeah yeah
but I think she probably wants that but
can I be may be made by how can you grow
when people like we've seen it like I've
gone after Jerry Seinfeld like three
times
like literally before he even says the
word sustain innovation because he's
earned it and how do you know you've
heard comics about how do you know they
even like the material you know what
with comedy you do no with comedy you
get two minutes okay okay how many you
get two minutes of oh my god it's you
Wow can you believe this I can't believe
it and then it's like huh
I thought this guy was funny I've seen
that before but but don't you think
instead of going through that two
minutes rather just show up pop in and
then hey you know what is what it is you
know the Comedy Store the Comedy Store
that's what's so great about the Comedy
Store that that does not matter like at
the Comedy Store Chris Rock pops in to
work on his set yeah you know all these
guys are coming into work and I said
even if they're getting like though but
the people know like okay now let us see
we're just gonna happen right now so
there's still a pre you still learn you
can still appreciate the process do you
you know what do you do you bomb still
oh yeah but do you enjoy that sitting in
the projects you don't think about it
anymore I have a point of Evanson point
of emphasis when I go on stage so if
like if I'm going on stage and I'm like
I want to work on this one bit all I
care about is that one bit I'm crafting
it and everything else is like just
gravy
when did you cuz to me you know like
when I perform in Hollywood the only
place to me I always want to like crush
but but at the same time because you
never know who's there but I love the
comics like you that you just said that
I spoke to some other ones where you
could just let it go I don't care who's
there
imma be me like I was sucking Sarah
Silverman of course she's prominent
people right at this point yeah but like
she literally takes out a piece of paper
and try stuff in front of a sold-out
crowd
you see at that point like they're there
already like for me like I don't know if
I I'm in a weird spot because I'm not
necessarily I'm not there I'm not one of
those people you know what I'm saying
and so for me that's why I do feel
pressure and more so now - especially at
the Comedy Store because it's such a
heavy hitter play yeah there's not a
workout room anymore it definitely it's
like a show you know that you go in
there you gotta like especially where
I'm at in the lineup
I'm not going up early or late I'm going
it'll be like you know you know chrisley
go joe rogan me you know you know my
father
okay I gotta come bring it in and still
get nervous no no no go you know you
know what makes you nervous is like
who's in the crowd you know like if I if
I was at a redneck bar
Iowa I'm shooting a movie or something
like that and I was like I'll do some
time but if somebody walked up to me and
said hey I think Spielberg's in the
crowd he's looking for her that's all
[ __ ] what's at stake you don't I mean
like what's at stake which is probably
why sometimes people like don't do as
well on their specials you know like I
feel like this that special I just put
out American warrior on Showtime but
it's Showtime but um I feel like that
set could have been a lot better I feel
like do you feel happy with it but I'm
saying I had to do it all again I would
do it differently did you feel like you
were rushed into it all I was very
rushed you know but I love the work that
I put in to get ready yeah that was the
kind of work I was like I need to do
this kind of work all the time with my
stand-up you know because I had to do
sets in tanks I was shooting a show at
the same time so I was like do an hour
Brea hour at Irvine hour and Oxnard out
you know I was doing all these like sets
like in the belly room at the haha so
you know what I mean just like to
prepare I couldn't go out of town yeah I
love like I'm hearing a couple stories
of comedians that put out specials and
now they're like you know I wish I would
have taken my time but also the thing is
when you get an opportunity you can't
say no because that opportunity may not
come back around well but again we're
still in this mode of like what we think
it specials are special and they're just
not it's content they're not special
they're just content that's our YouTube
videos that's our you know our big you
know that's our big like hey this is my
new thing I'm putting out and then next
year I'll put out another one and
another one do you think that applies to
all comics like specials are gone yeah
they're not special anymore you don't I
mean this and it depends on who how it's
being put out like you know Chappelle
just you know put out that he put out
five specials in two years yeah what's
special about that you know I mean it's
not special and then because he's so
large and so big and such a dynamic
personality now he's cornered the market
on stand up whereas like if he doesn't
do it or if he does it he's the only one
that can do it yeah you know and so
he'll say something on the thing and
it's like Oh only Chappelle can talk
about Michael Jackson like only
Chappelle can talk about like
transgender people you know I mean
that's like his Hot Pockets yeah you
know I mean like Jim Jim got you know I
mean like Jim Gaffigan did the hot
pocket thing and I everybody was like
you can't talk about how
his credit you could like this the way
he you don't I mean so now it's like
heavy hitting issues and stand up there
now support their now looked at is like
well that Chappelle's domain see or
Chris Rock yeah but but but Chris Rock
only comes he does specials because they
only come out every you know five so
there are specials but right now the the
the rate you're getting them from
certain comedians that makes them not
special yeah they're not it's just
content so it's great like you know it's
like here's this person that you like
really admire like you know like
Chappelle's like so dynamic you go to
say that's the thing now and good for
Netflix being like we don't care what
blowback we get we don't care what
happened let's put this content out you
know what I mean well what's great
Netflix twenty million dollars or this
Eddie Murphy seventy million dollars
like people don't realize like they
think it's a lot of money and which it
is but for Netflix they do sometimes
series that cost two hundred fifty to
three hundred million dollars that bomb
nobody watches so at least they know by
paying a tenth of what these big
produced TV shows twenty million people
are gonna watch it so actually it's
smarter for Netflix I know and the thing
about it is there's also there's also
less pressure for so much this is why so
it's a great situation because you know
he's like a giant in comedy right he's
already got to money yeah he does no I'm
saying they they paid him for like he's
a here's my special I delivered it they
it takes for the money then they put it
up whenever they want
yeah no but but for him it's like okay I
I'm done you all you people that are
like canceling and all this kind of
stuff he's like [ __ ] yeah I don't care
don't even get me started on that whole
cancel culture is so ridiculous this
whole cancel culture it's like here's
the problem and I understand because I
interview a lot of people in the
Hollywood and out outside of Hollywood
and the hypocrisy is so big and I would
put money by that so there's this grano
named Nicole Arbour and she's very
came out with a video I've only known
her for probably like a month and a half
but you know I know she has a history of
being very controversial she put out a
video about fat people shaming them she
was on the view and they kind of went
after her and but III invited her to a
comedy club you know cuz we're friends
and then a comic took issue oh I
remember this Oh were you there that
night no I wasn't dinner that but I know
what you're talking about so it was that
fat girl that was on that one show right
listen this happened like five years ago
yes yeah okay so so yeah this girl makes
a video about that I guess yes so that's
her the girl so and she's known and I
don't even know if that's true but she's
known as a Republican and she felt it
for Trump whatever so I'm standing there
I bring it to a comedy club she's
watching the set uh and I was
introducing two people and then one
comment got so mad I'm not gonna say who
it is got so mad and go do you know this
person they they they support Trump and
they made a video about fat people and I
go but she thinks she's a comedian like
this Nicole girls she's like I'm a
comedian this was fun content so in my
mind I go do you know how many comics we
know that say awful [ __ ] on stage yeah
like for instance this is the hypocrisy
she makes these videos and things that
she's big
Nicole is huge on the internet but this
person is hating on this girl for being
a comedian doing it through the internet
when you have and I love them but like
Anthony Jeselnik that says crazy [ __ ]
like crazy [ __ ] like like which is funny
I love it stand up but I know you're
good friends with that person and you
have no problem with his content but you
have problem with this girl just called
people fat
Anthony talks about killing babies like
oh like you having a alters or sometimes
they think that that's more existential
the problem is the fat the fat is fat
like if you call somebody fat it's cuz
they're fat she was she was just talking
about fat people in general no I know I
get it I have yeah I'm a fat guy and I
talk about fat people yeah so my thing
is like Huck it is hypocrisy it's like
straight-up
hypocrisy like when you have an Anthony
Jeselnik talking about terrible awful
things and then
saying awful things on tweets which I
love is comedy don't get me wrong I'm
not going after him because I think it's
funny I think he's funny but how can you
say one you justify one because they're
a big comedian and they sell so here's
the thing those are not justifying
anymore
right now as I look what this is what
I'm saying the the type of like
left-wing you know critical [ __ ]
Chappelle went through with his special
is that's the cancel culture right there
yeah I'll talk about all these big
publications talking about don't watch
it all these kind of things and I mean
over a hundred thousand people gave it
ninety nine percent on rotten tomato you
just go like it's just it's proof that
like it's actually proof that cancel
culture isn't a real thing it's just
putting this [ __ ] until the people that
got fired from it I know but you know
but but but what we're starting to find
out is like the actual people actually
are not they're not the ones that are
it's not many it's not many but the many
is not many but the not so many are very
powerful
III I'm not against the Dave Chappelle
cuz Dave Chappelle has nothing to lose
but light I've talked about this before
like me and maybe you yes I always say
that kind of [ __ ] because I'm still
trying to come up like so that that can
hurt you yes I get look what it did look
at the guy look at uh Shane give us your
SNL okay so he's on this podcast yeah I
think this is like I'm thinking is this
a safe space
can we talk about things say then I
realize oh no nothing so I do have to be
measured and thoughtful about what I say
right now because somebody might look
back and be like well you know you said
this and then here you go you're being
judged by that one sentence is your
whole character so you know what was
interesting on the Dave Chappelle
special he talked about a reporter
coming to a show and talking about Jesse
Smollett right my thing when reporters
or people report what they see in a
comedy club if you're a writer and you
turn it you would never turn in your
first draft you know that draft has been
over and over so literally when you see
a comic and a comedy club if it's not
his special that's a rough draft of what
he's trying to get to and nobody ever
turns into rough Jess so you're judging
them on something that's not even
developed they're just writing it
yes weird you know but writer
who write per a profession will attack
these comics when they're just listening
to a rough draft but you would never
turn in your first draft of you
complaining about that comic it goes
through an editor they edit it then you
get back you make your tweak it goes
four or five different steps before it's
published so but you're not giving the
same credit to a comic that's working
out stuff in a club trying to get it to
publish which is our support even
somebody like say on a podcast or just
having a discussion or somebody thinks
something's funny and it's a little
off-color and then the next thing you
know like your your whole character is
being assassinated like you're that
person but it that's true but you got to
remember too is that you're putting it
out I know that's what I said too about
Anne and I are like I know that I had
somebody write there was this this one
just [ __ ] troll idiot on my troll
he's a troll idiot it's like riding on
my comments about like you know you you
shouldn't be saying stuff about shame
you know you you know he's a comic too
you should be supporting him cuz all I
said on projects I was just like I just
like it wasn't my cup of tea what he
said you know like I listen to and I was
like I this isn't my thing
you know okay first of all it wasn't
your cup of tea and to me it wasn't
funny you know it was but what I'm
saying is that doesn't matter because it
doesn't matter because it's like in the
context of a conversation of things that
they're talking about like it doesn't it
like the prerequisite for a podcast is
not that it has to be funny
like if you're at just having a
conversation you say something off-color
there are people out there that are
gonna be like I agree with that guy or
or whatever their thing they're gonna
say so like I wrecked respect when I
look back on it it's like I could care
less if it was funny or not it's just
like I'm saying I'm thinking about it as
a podcast creator now as like what kind
of content do I want to put out and it's
like damn like he made me go oh maybe
it's like you even though this is my
thing and it's my content and I look it
has an effect it does what people got to
realize is when you put stuff out like
this podcast and we both do in our
podcast but if you get an SNL gig I get
an SNL get guess what trolls are going
through all your stuff you put out
find something that you said and my
particular god I did it he's a comic and
he's just the worst but but it's a thing
where you got a no and it's terrible but
you got to know whatever you say on any
TV show on any podcast no matter where
you are if you get that golden gig if
you're if you get that press release
where Eric Griffin got his own show on
CBS and guess what the imagine just so
four of riffin with Griffin yeah it's
coming it's coming it's coming
so that's the thing that even Melissa
Villasenor when she first got on SNL she
had something in a tweet that she had
said and they were trying to like I
think okay that gets to everybody but
they you know but but some last some
doesn't like there's different things
you can attack and you know like he
attacked Asians no I well and Asians
right now have a lot light I don't think
it was about that what do you think is
about no it was about it was about him
being a straight white male you think
that's why they were all yeah if it was
a Asian saying the same thing it
wouldn't matter it was a black dude
saying that they would have been like
that was off-color but I don't think he
would have got fired I think when right
now is like it's like payback mode right
now I said you know so so like you know
it's like straight it's very unfortunate
to be a white male yeah right well no
it's not it's just like oh sorry but
it's weird what they're doing right now
no it's very weird because it's a thing
where everybody came out and talked
about all my friends that are Asian you
know was it a thing in the Asian
community well know what it was like it
that was a talk you know it's almost
like how can this guy just say this and
we not say something about it because I
have said about it for years but now
they can yeah and and that's where it
comes to freedom of speech like this
whole freedom of speech thing I love it
when somebody gets in trouble for
freedom of speech and they go there
trying to take away my freedom of speech
they're like no but you had your freedom
uh sweet yeah now you got a little bit's
getting mad so because I'm gonna if it
turns then people get the
OSHA's all we're gonna be like no but
here's the thing about sorry Willie
Purdue here's the thing about freedom of
speech you know yes I said this and now
it's okay for people to be like I didn't
like it
you know it's like why do people think
like it's so [ __ ] stupid what's that
lady on Fox Laura Ingraham like she'll
say some crazy [ __ ] and then all
responses to drop them drop her and then
she goes you're trying to take away my
freedom of speech it's know the people
you said about they have their freedom
of speech to call advertisers is it it
what that the what white privilege that
sounds like yeah you know I mean like
just like I could say whatever I want
and you should still have to sponsor me
now it don't work like that
no it's like that sponsors go okay
enough people don't and that's the thing
about the st. Gilles thing I think it
just got to a point where it was like
they were way in it okay
they were weighing it and it was so much
backlash and he's they hired another
white guy they were just like let's jam
it was the first Asian American but they
hired at the same time at the same time
so I was like they did it on purpose you
know they said they knew about the clip
fortunate time we're living in society
right now they were overly sensitive to
that and my saying is right at all you
know I know I have a lot you know like
there's a lot of I've had discussions
with I was in this movie and I was
talking to one of the lead actors he's
just like macho dude Italian you know I
mean and he's just like going in about
like I can't I can't get parts you know
he's like you know like now I'm losing
parts to women I lose the part you know
you know you know and and in his mind to
he's like like the parts I'm losing to
you like it's like like a Navy SEAL you
know like you know things like that so
they're all like there's a lot of
straight white males out there who were
like look I've never been racist I've
never done anything bad to women and why
am i being lumped in with everybody and
I go yo you know what I hear you but you
know what you also weren't there to help
me you know you weren't on my side
either you were a lot of those type of
people are on this kind of like hear no
evil see no evil say no evil
you know but you know you
oh no I know exactly I married a white
woman from Wyoming right so here's
what's interesting is after we had our
kid like people gotta understand if it's
not around you or doesn't affect you you
don't care usually that's the way it
works and my wire enough has never gone
through an ethnic battle police
brutality any the my family my wife's
fan is the Brady Bunch
it's literally the Brady Bunch right so
it's very simple storm iie after we had
our son you know now my wife notices
when black people get shot my wife
notices when black people get beat my
wife notices when ethnic people are done
wrong into justice system because she
looks at her son and goes oh now this
effect like I'm thinking in her head she
goes oh this affects me now right so if
it if she had a white kid and was
married to a white man she would still
not be paying attention to what I'm
saying so like these guys these are the
comics and actors who are like you know
at Tony Hinchcliffe on you know Tony was
great he was all into he's like look man
two straight white males like you know
no more movies for others custom when I
go okay I'm in mind I'm like alright
this is cool man sorry that you don't
have your time anymore like you do
usually goes through cycles you know but
it's like I always say like you know I
have to those guys that are saying to me
the day to do anything wrong you also
didn't do much to help and you know how
I know this cuz I didn't do much for
women yeah so I know that you know why
would you do stuff for other ethnic
groups when I know like we knew about
casting couches and all these things
that were going on and women don't get
enough you know opportunities we've been
around for this for art forever all of a
sudden we needed me to and and Cosby and
Harvey Weinstein we needed all this to
happen for one you knew it was a
supposed to start to go oh yeah that is
messed up we weren't doing anything
either so it's like I understand why
white straight males haven't done [ __ ]
to help the cause because it didn't
affect them if it doesn't affect you you
don't care like just to put it in
perspective we have still soldiers dying
overseas but since it's not front and
center on the news people forget about
it and if it doesn't affect you it
doesn't
effect you like and I'm learning that
first thing with my wife now she whoa
she's very small she what a mark like no
she's becoming very whoa like even more
because I hope not not like not over but
like for instance she'll just notice
like when even something simple like we
watch The Bachelor together because
that's her thing but they had a bachelor
name that's not your thing no no you
love it I love it I do it's so funny a
big brother I love big brother yeah so
I'm watching this and my wife is very
upset because Big Mike was the black guy
that was on the show and he should be
about 100% fan favorite he should be the
bachelor but I know television and I've
talked to people that worked for that
show there's no way they're gonna make a
black man The Bachelor because that
means he has to make out with white
chicks and middle America needs to watch
that there's no way they would watch
that they had a commercial four years
ago I think it was Cheerios where they
had an interracial couple the white
woman was in the kitchen with her mixed
son the husband was in the living not
even in the same room the living room
and they got complaints and they and
people went off about that so it's just
out there and you got to understand but
if I'm ABC I'm going if I'm management
okay well I'm not being racist I just
understand our demographic well this is
the thing too that gets me about like
the woke culture and cancel and it's all
coastal it's all coastal liberal urban
cities who think that they have the
pulse of America and you obviously don't
cuz knows why Trump got elected you know
you know what I mean that's why like
that's why NCIS is still one of the
biggest shows on TV absolutely they
don't know what's going they don't know
what people think what they're going
through they don't you know these people
on this Coast and on Twitter they think
that they had the pulse of America you
don't yeah I just I feel like and I grew
up in Texas so I feel like it's a type
of thing where middle America is they
look at the left in and they look at the
left coast and right coast and they go
hypocrisy like what kind of your hip
announcing your hypocrites you know I
can show you ten things you're
complaining about our person but I can
show you ten
things your person did the exact same
but you're not looking at yes and I
think and I think that's the big problem
is middle America to me is this audience
right here hey whatever you're doing
don't bother us about it we're just
gonna keep doing our thing yeah we don't
get an hour don't get in our business
because we know you don't really care
yeah you're not our busy care yeah you
know you're not here you don't know you
can talk about oh you talk about this on
the left you can talk about this in New
York but you don't know what we're going
through in the middle they don't know
people they're going through they just
don't they don't because you're not
around it so why talk about it you know
so when I lived in Texas look I was that
dude I vote a Republican when I was in
Texas uh and I didn't know any different
because that's the way you grow up you
know but now even my wife moved to from
Wyoming which is very rebuttal yeah now
she's like oh with this guy saying and I
don't want to get political but I don't
agree with the thoughts that people are
saying on a certain size so I'm gonna go
to the other side now right so you
learned that moving or I think there's
especially in Houston there's this big
where I'm from it's a lot of blue coming
into Houston because people are getting
more educated about like oh you don't
have to think a certain way but like in
middle America it's just leave us alone
we just want to do our thing and leave
us alone some people in America like
sorry I don't know any black people it's
you know that you don't I mean you know
I'm saying it's like so like you're in
Middle America some little town it's
like you know 5,000 people is all white
you know you casually have a black
person coming through who knows on the
basketball team from the county across
the 181 the teams play like you DS you
know but like you know it's like it's
hot it's hard for me to say to like
people who have never you know to have
empathy when they have their own
problems going on it's just a tough
thing I I do I do think you know I was
talking to some people in III feel like
in going to that white argument I feel
that a lot of times like I was talking
to one of my white friends and he goes
you know what I hate every time I watch
the news it's us doing something you
know it's us he said and he's a great
guy and like you said he's never
supported but it's kind of like it's
almost like a black person looking at TV
gone every time somebody's getting
arrested it's black
which is true pretty much but there are
a lot of white people getting arrested
to that you don't show but now why is
what I was talking about Theo my white
men are talking about hey why is it
everybody blaming us the white man where
there's black police officers beating
down black people - yeah you know doing
a legal [ __ ] well here's the thing it's
funny you say that because there was
this white Republican conservative
ex-cop who sent me an email after I was
on Thea's podcast and he was like man I
wanna come on your podcast cuz I wrote a
book and I and I want to talk to the
other side you know and it's like I
haven't gotten back to him you know I
should actually you know because and I'm
like my thing about it is it's like what
he doesn't understand it's like how how
great that is see like all this backlash
right now boss straight white males
they're getting it oh yeah all right but
they also have the ability to be like
hey what do you what are you guys
getting on us for we're not all bad and
they're there fighting for their rights
not everybody got that privilege to do
that cuz when they did it was looked at
it's like that like Oh with that civil
rights now or like you know it always
has to be on that side of it you know
what I mean it's the angry black man or
one or you get you get labeled that
wouldn't ya whatever oh here we go
you know what it is but it's like they
were able now they're still taking
advantage of white privilege yeah but on
the other side so it's so strange it
they don't see this guy in particular
doesn't see it like that
it was like yes he's like not all cops
are bad I got of course I don't think
all cops are no of course not I know
there's a lot it's a tough job it's an
underpaid job you know you know people
have to deal with so much in that
profession you know what I mean I have a
friend of my fantasy fantasy league
that's a cop you know what I mean they
have to deal with a lot of sound like
the person that says I got a black
friend you can't win
yeah but I I feel that it's the news the
news is the biggest problem oh I told
the news is the biggest problem because
they will hide they want the race war
because that sells and that gets people
to watch they want to find like they're
not looking for the black on black crime
or they're not looking for the white on
white crime they're looking for the
white
arresting a black dude and beating them
down because I guarantee you there's
just as many videos of a white dude
beating down a white dude or a black cop
beating down a black cop but they know
what people will watch is the black guy
beating on a white guy or white watch
cops yeah so so it's all white
that's all white on white half the time
that's right and they're videotaping so
you're not seeing the bad stuff but that
the news is selling that Mary let's end
on this so talking about this because I
was just thinking about this last night
so I'm so glad you brought this up you
know right now because the 2020 election
is coming up right and so what I don't
understand is like if you turn on Fox
News you would think that every Democrat
is crazy
yep and then you turn on CNN and you
would think that every Republican is
corrupt and and you know and it's
there's like there's no middle ground on
any station because they found out
middle ground doesn't rate well no
because the audience it's frustrating
here's the thing is the audience once TV
cable news became about money and
ratings that's when it's like okay they
saw five CNN Saul Fox and how successful
they were they were going oh we're just
gonna be the Fox at the other side now I
why seeing in more than Fox but I like
to watch Bob I'm a person who I watch
both I got to be educated on both sides
you know but but it's a thing once it
became about ratings
so CNN took it way right and here's the
problem with the news is they will take
the craziest person that is opposite
them and give that person airtime like
seeing them will put the craziest right
person they where Donald Trump can do
anything well it's got a point you know
that and then Fox will take the craziest
right person there's no they don't put
people that have common sense they just
let report the other part I would just
like to see you like about the
impeachment you know I would love to see
someone on Fox say that like maybe it's
a good idea and I'd like to see someone
on CNN be like well I don't know if we
should do this like there's just none of
that it's like the party line is just
but the only time you'll hear on CNN I
don't think we should do this is because
you might lose the next
like that's always a tack I don't know
if they should do this because it could
have felt where where my dad no my dad
went through segregation he marked led
marches and things like that so it's
interesting to me I had a conversation
with him and he's the one that kind of
slapped me in the right direction I go
well why should they impeach Trump
because or even try to because they're
not gonna get it through the Republican
to do the Senate yeah and he goes
because it's right because he did a lot
of wrong and and I go I was thinking
just like a politician I was like well
they could lose this they could lose
that and my dad goes no forget about
that you need to do what's right and
what's wrong if you have this proof that
it's wrong you need to do the inquiry
yeah well here's the thing though I have
a feel this is what this is the only
times just only politics we're gonna get
it too right yeah is this the reason why
they want to impeach him cuz there's no
way they're gonna win an election I
disagree but that's why I think I think
the only not one of these [ __ ]
ago I think that oh and I'm gonna end on
this the only way I think Trump loses is
if he goes against Biden because I feel
like older white people love to vote for
older white people yeah but that's him
and I when I say no but they want or
they want to get I feel like changes
it's like it's like date it's like
dating you'll date a crazy person and
then you're like I I need to date
somebody normal you know cuz the last
relationship was great you already ever
go too crazy too crazy
you always like okay I'm looking for
something I wish that were true cuz I
keep I'm actually I just went back to
crazy well that's your bad I didn't even
say that yeah I just recently got back
with my ex okay because we've changed so
much we worked we worked it out we
worked it out she worked it out she's
right it's still crazy is that what you
say yeah but yeah cuz it's like because
if before if I broke up because I was
like I don't like all this distance and
this and then like you know I I see a
pattern of all the women that I've dated
I'm like well apparently they're all got
something going on but you know you look
at the history of presidents it's kind
of like you have one that goes like
people at the time like Bush was crazy I
mean if you look at today it's not but
backed in crazy so they brought it back
and you do the dance
it always waits so I feel like no matter
what the Republicans do they're not
gonna win because I think it's all about
independence and do you know who put
Trump into the White House was the
college-educated women that's the
biggest demographic that the Democrats
nice women white women white white
educated women put trumpet to the white
house it's a fact you can look it up so
I just think those white educated women
going oh what we do we'll see we'll see
but I just think but I think it's if
it's anybody besides Biden they will
lose because in America that middle
America part the one they're like hey
you left for you you West Coasters and
East Coasters leave us alone we're used
to vote and I'm talking when I say older
white people I mean like 68 65 said
we're used to voting for white people
that are older don't bother us we're
gonna keep doing it and I feel like
that's the Joe Biden we'll see man but I
just really feel like they pushing this
I think they're really pushing this
impeachment cuz it's like well this is
gonna be our we have a better chance but
they're not gonna give you if you were
vote if you're a betting would you bet
on what's but what's that what what's
the odds on getting Trump out of office
impeachment or election no you it's the
election is it 50 fit no it's not even
close with impeachment it's not gonna
happen
yeah I know well they don't have the
Senate yeah so they're gonna lose that
fight but they're joined with a lot the
other might now I believe they're not
gonna get enough Republicans to go
against the press I mean that's the
honest fact like they're not gonna get
the impeachment so what you're saying is
kind of wrong they have to rely on the
election I don't know I
what I'm saying is I know they should
rely on the election but I'm saying to
you as I think it there's they know that
they don't have a great shot but but the
he's not gonna get in people I know but
that's but they still gotta go for it
yeah they have the moral high ground to
like I mean you have and that was what
my dad said he's like forget it all the
political movies you got do it because
it's wrong we'll see it's gonna be a
it's gonna be oh this is not a funny
podcaster David I thought we got so
serious that's great I just was talking
about this on this other thing it just
doesn't matter that's not why people
watch yeah they actually they don't were
they just watch for whatever an
authentic conversation yeah so don't
worry don't worry I stopped worrying
about that so long ago this a stand-up
man it's a
different platform and it's like they
just want like we we obviously are good
with each other so that's all they
really care about did you feel about it
did you feel a lot of pressure because
the own Rogan when you've heard like oh
I gotta be funny the hotel no I thought
about it really
I know we talked about that yeah I never
even thought about I just was like you
know I I just went on and we just had a
conversation it's just like I just just
be myself you know that's what you gotta
do yeah that's what you told me that but
I was still kind of I get it but like
three hours later you're like oh my god
yeah we still talk I'm jealous that
you're here too I need some hair like
how do you got such good hair like you
know what it is I've been taking vitamin
D with k12 I've been taking my
supplements and vitamins I've been
working out more I've been watching you
know I'm trying to get you know cuz of
my mom no cuz of my mom's condition I've
started thinking to myself you know what
I don't want to be like this I need to
you know you know I've taken tumeric I'm
saying you know they're too and the
vitamin D I know it's directly related
to like just just lovely mane no it's
nice I keep going talking to a ponytail
well maybe that'll be your thing you
know Ali Wong came out with the belly
and she blew I know now you could be the
redneck sky was amazing he crushed Amy
that'll be the thing that pops I don't
know is that we're always on a quest to
find out it's so crazy that you know we
talk about all the time and it's such a
stupid conversation it's like what is
that one thing to make you pop you just
never know no but it's not even just
that it's just funny how everybody wants
to do what everybody else is doing you
know that's the first you brought up
Andrew Schultz and I can i you know
about oh he showed us a different way
and I tell in comics are telling me that
all the time I go but that's just him
name another one that has done that oh
no there's no what I mean there's a lot
of people out did it put that Derek 100%
money on the internet now this game you
know I don't know he's like it makes it
special because it's his and and usually
when you're the first to do like at that
big capacity you know like he's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] y'all I'm doing on my own but
it's only because they said [ __ ] you
that's why exactly that's what it's not
what you know any it be different to if
everybody was like all these networks
were like we want to put your special on
yeah he was I
now yeah but do it myself yeah so a four
it was forced to do it himself you just
he just did it well you know what the
right and that's the thing is kind of
like right or wrong way mine's not all
right that's what I'm trying to tell you
there's no right or wrong way I'm not
saying it I just want to be accepted
that's it I don't really care
yeah okay but I don't really care
that's what's so weird man it's so weird
listen man you're doing fine you know
what I mean just keep keep that keep
just keep the hope alive just Rock I'm
just telling you keep hope alive keep
hope alive just keep doing what you're
doing you know what I mean look yeah
you're on my podcast I mean I hated you
you know I made it that same you did
rogue yeah people like you so it's just
like you know you you know what I
realize is like haters are always gonna
hate and but and that we can use that as
fuel or we can or we can like let it
fester and we never move forward so you
use it as fuel oh yeah you see me I
don't even think about it
I love having enemies I like oh do you
yeah I leave that I love to like prove
people wrong and that kind of stuff see
I've never been into that I just do me
yeah I'm just doing a check no I gave
Reverend yo over like I said nobody like
I gotta hang out on comedy clubs more so
I can hear hate like I just never like I
just never like I don't know why it's
just like no so you're saying people
will and I know we gotta end this but
when you hear negative stuff about
yourself comics will say that in your
face yeah yeah no no oh
secondhand stuff I've heard things about
people that I love though I want to talk
to them about it I mean you're not gonna
like it here's the thing though I don't
care in a sense of like like if somebody
I get the Comedy Store not everyone at
The Comedy Store even in the heart of
the the main lineup thinks that each
other is funny okay that's just wait
they there's people in the heart of the
lineup they might think that another
person in the lineup they might not
think that person is funny or they know
or it's not their style of house exactly
so it's you're always gonna have that
, stores really like that it's like it's
like it's like the high school cafeteria
man you know what I mean so there's like
you know mr. cool kids
oh the podcasters you know what I mean
Oh famous people all the people the
movies and TV it's very much look at
high school it's like let me girls let
me be honest when I'm at the Comedy
Store the heavy hitters the big people
like you and the Sebastien's and the
billboard
when they perform they don't swatch of
it like I never seen a big comedian
watch other comedians it's more of only
become a night only if they only if they
are like right after yeah I go you know
you don't mean so I I can't imagine
those people talking [ __ ] I normally see
the people that are trying to come up
but here's a thing that they do watch to
people that they want to watch I've seen
it they you know they'll watch people
they'll talk about them Rogan talks
about his favorite comics on his podcast
all the time yeah this guy's funny you
know he's a kingmaker you don't know how
Thrones yeah so you know so it's there
it happened Joe Rogan is I Chelsea used
to be when she had her show I tell
everybody Chelsea was the American Idol
I was on that show and every time I see
the the what was his name Mike Michael
Cox
yeah I mean so like he had me on another
show later yeah and he was like oh man
you know it was like I was like yeah you
never had me on Chelsea's like I'm sorry
so you cost me because that's what it is
because she was like the American Idol
of comedian you could have no career be
on her show sellout and I feel like
Rogan is that person for comics and for
workout people and for UFC like he's the
king right like you said you on his
podcast it's it's a game change but
annointed just like this one all right
well we're gay we're getting there we're
getting there man listen I'm glad you
came on appreciate you I'm gonna come to
yours yes and you know III I feel your I
feel what you're going through I you
know I know you listen the thing is
you're a positive guy and it's
equivalent to being a bitter guy okay
this same energy comes out some people
think that me see people's positive
people think that I'm just gonna be
positive all right you know what
I love everybody say it out it's trance
nor do I do ya see no I do I honestly I
don't other far I don't dislike
anyone it's not about dislike what I'm
saying is the feelings that you still
might have towards like they're people
that talk [ __ ] or like oh yeah it's all
the same coming from an angry side or
coming from a friendly side it still
meets it in the same it's still
frustrated it's still frustrating so
what I'm trying to say is like you know
we're both still trying to overcome
those things but that's part of what
like drives us to be better comedians
and better actors better people yeah
100% you know what I mean all right guys
I might have all of Mike's information
down below make sure you check that out
it's got a great podcast you can find
I'm on a bunch of things actually you
still on the radio show too right yeah I
got a couple radio shows podcasts and
then my special you can still watch it
and approach specials on Amazon Prime
what's the name of it blasian make sure
you check out blasian on amazon prime
and all the other information will be
down below make sure you guys subscribe
share send put your comments even you
trolls you know you know me I see them
so don't worry are you right back to the
troll or something yeah my favorite
that's wasted like a trolls gonna like
the trolls gonna read something go oh
you make a good point though that's not
about no I'm not trying to make a good
point they're not trying to make a good
point why should I try to make it right
back hey get the [ __ ] off my page and
never come back
I'm just saying you wasting energy
okay not all the time I don't do it all
the time I shall read comics I don't
recover I know I shouldn't but when I'm
checking things that comment pops up and
I'm like why would you say that you know
what you probably have no vacations but
by the time I you are a do with
notifications on so you know when oh I
had to turn the notifications okay
because of that but I actually hit it
Rogan about this I said dude when did
you stop looking at comments he was like
a long time ago and he was like and I
don't look at the positive voice he said
the positive ones could be just as
detrimental to your psyche
absolute I was like okay so I'm not as
bad as I was
you know but I can I just but
occasionally there'll be a comment and
I'm like if somebody's rude to the guest
I don't like that yeah
you know somebody says something like
it's okay to say like I don't think that
guy's funny or but to say some
disparaging [ __ ] that I'm like now you
got to get off my page
Balam you use you block oh yes you gon
see here we go here's what's interesting
you gone we talked about the comments
but you know you could take the comments
off of everything if you really didn't
want the comments that's my thing I
always say I geez people that complain
about their comments turn them off turn
you can turn them off but you want to
cut because you want the reinforcement
of oh you look beautiful you look like I
know so you got to deal with the
negative that's our egos but and that's
why I look at both I love it
I'll leave my comments on because all
these discussions happen that stuff's
fun to look at sometimes how a thing
will break out oh yeah and then people
start fighting with yeah yeah I love
looking at that that's a common and
fight with each other online
well thank you listen guys thanks for
listening to mix race car race podcast
there it is I got enough black in me you
know it's Caribbean black we should
start podcast call it mixed up mixed
there it is I don't we should we're
mixed up why not like stop mixed up with
Mike and Eric
look look file for that you know yeah
mixed up I you know what I'm just gonna
have you on again then we'll keep doing
it if people like it they will know we
can do it we were I do yours I don't
think this one's good I mean we talked
this guy really thinks this about guys
about being funny and it's just not
telling it is it really is it may be
your audience is different but you know
it's all you think we see people
laughing at Rogen's podcast half the
time these funny things happen but he's
yeah he really needs to be organic yes
you know what it is you're still in host
mode no no hosting we're not funny now
me Tommy but but there's like I've
always presented cuz I wanted to be
funny but I this was a very real
conversation you never have real
conversations on your podcast of course
but I'm interviewing people so that's
different yeah as a guest I wanna I want
to give more
I want to keep you more you're so
worried is your problem
I work yeah this is your problem right
here so you wanna be accepted but I
don't care
you've been trying to in this podcast 20
minutes that's gonna be the name that's
gonna be the title of Mike's new book I
want to be that that will recept it but
I don't care
that'll be a great name for a podcaster
I want to be accepted without okay then
we just get everybody's yeah stories
stories about acceptance you know what
we're gonna talk about this off yeah you
guys have been great thanks for watching
River where for now see you next week
later